okay we're back um not really much to
say yeah then we're doing work from
Raleigh episode two you know oh wait let
me move this little I see that it's
blocking a little bit I'll be over here
you know just just I'm just going over
here and I don't my knight just I'll be
over here if you need me you know um
let's see here and what is that okay
here we go let's do that episode two
now it's important I remember that
because it's an interactive story and
they're like there were kind of filmed
separately like they're not all on one
unit so the choices in this one the
chosen the first one do not impact the
choices in this episode because there's
just not like software it doesn't
remember your actions they're like
really separately on the website like
months later and it's not like telltale
you know so okay it may be look
confusing the way it starts out okay
just a warning can you see her mouth I
hope you can see my mouth well enough
okay here we go
oh no she's running a sir sir I need a
bathroom badly hey says God said I need
a little boy God they're out for the
night
hips Karnas hey I'm killing people um
Teddy long dead I think Morgan's a
little sound oh my god calm down um hey
your eminence
yeah you know locked door I would a
locked door why do you lock door what is
she doing taking a selfie of our house
anybody maker and I I think I witnessed
a murder tonight I don't know what to do
her for who you tellin you better lock
that door girl you better lock that door
oh no don't look in the holes you see
the tweet your GPS coordinates for here
what is it
why won't he let us it
are they all like killers why does it
girl blood red yeah shut them out bro
you got this brow shut lock them out got
got everything go get your gun brah oh
good my tongue to people outside but do
not open
oh the garage door isn't open what are
you doing your market
what day please I was just on our sauce
gaming minding my own business I don't
know what he wants oh she was on reddit
she's a reddit account I'm listening to
marques
thank you
I stabbed my friend why what you know a
relevance fallacy pick a premise exit
the conclusions it's the point answer
the question we missed Oh some architect
that tax who are you talking to
everybody nobody not working you better
pop this guy just pop up just pop up I'm
just messing is he driving I don't know
about any of this he's been murdering
people
Abbi we have to make him talk absolutely
make him talk
okay Marcus grab his leg make him open -
yeah get his kneecaps
guys guys gotta get dad daddy why are
you telling me though killing a muon no
you may not seem sad for what am i even
mean let's see what's behind I number
two yes get up get up get up
this makes no sense have you get it
who the heck are you oh that girl's cool
actually right video experience is great
um okay that's episode of that episode
on yep tell Sunday Josh angle said next
one